son rôle de juge sera une belle
parenthèse au fond au milieu de la
multitude de projets qu'il a sur la
table parce qu'on le connaît xavier
dolan céline il est très très prolifique
un film par année depuis 2009 et puis
cette pause depuis momie plus rien donc
que ses fans qui sont très nombreux ici
s'impatientait bas il va rattraper le
temps perdu
il va tourner deux films cette année un
film américain ce qu'il voulait faire
depuis longtemps
ça va se faire à l'automne de des
sunlights fav john donovan avec de ces
catcheurs steyn et puis avance à un
autre film production franco canadienne
qui va se tourner deux jours à peine
après la fin du festival ici ça va se
tourner à montréal avec des gros noms
encore là marion cotillard léa seydoux
nathalie baye gaspard ulliel et puis
vincent cassel
mais avant ça ben il encore beaucoup de
pain sur la planche xavier dollars ici
il a 19 films à voir et à juger pour
déterminer lequel d'entre eux méritent
la palme d'or ils attendent depuis cinq
jours s'accrochent à leur place comme si
leur vie en dépendait
tout cela pour avoir une chance
d'apercevoir les stars sur le tapis
rouge
un rituel qu'il répète depuis plus de 20
ans visiblement la magic cannes opère
toujours
l'objectif c'est de voir bon de faire
déjà de belles photos puisque en plus
bon les acteurs on les a vraiment tout
près et puis après derrière les
autographes dernière photo
9 la montée des marches du palais du
festival et chaque fois un moment fort
pour les fans comme pour les stars un
exercice auquel le jeune québécois
xavier dolan est habitué lui qui en est
à sa cinquième présence à cannes
même s'il vient cette fois non pas pour
défendre son film mais bien pour juger
ceux des autres un rôle qu'il aborde
avec enthousiasme moi je suis ici pour
comme il vient de le dire pour voir des
films en tant que cinéphile pour les
voir avec mon coeur ma responsabilité
n'est pas de les juger de les critiquer
de les catégoriser
ma responsabilité est très très simple
les essais de de déclarer humainement ce
qui ce qui qui me parle en fait ce qui
me touche
fait inusité le jury du festival à cette
année deux présidents les frères joel et
ethan coen auteur de films comme fargo
et no country for old men autour d'eux
d'autres stars comme jeff et sophie
marceau auront la lourde tâche de
choisir des gagnants parmi les 19 films
en compétition on est tous très
impatients de rentrer dans les salles de
cinéma et d'échangés ce que nous aimons
plus c'est à dire le cinéma je déclare
ouverte la 68e festive au deccan
officiellement ouverte
la grande fête mondiale du cinéma va se
poursuivre jusqu'au 24 mai prochain
toujours de paillettes et de strass de
tapis rouge et de stars en tenue de
soirée
douze jours de rêve et de déception
douze jours de cinéma
comme l'an dernier le québec est bien
représenté dans cette édition du
festival de cannes avec denis villeneuve
et son film sicario un film que le
réalisateur québécois considère comme
son meilleur jusqu'à présent et que
beaucoup de critiques de films place
parmi les favoris ici à cannes
il faut dire que la présence d'un
québécois parmi les membres du jury la
présence aussi de l'acteur fétiche de
villeneuve de grenoble ne devrait pas
nuire à ses chances
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
calmes